ce soir c'est top a consacré au jt qui
part en vrille on a des images vous
allez vous régaler comme tous les soirs
les chéris on va commencer à la 20e
place et dans un jt qui se passe en
suède ils ont envoyé un journaliste à
jérusalem pour un reportage sur le mur
des lamentations jusque là rien de
spécial sauf que il ya une meuf qui
s'est cru chez sa mère et cas soit tu es
complètement la caméra la tête et la
tête de la meuf est folle vous allez
voir vous la connaissez c'est là c'est
une amie me regarder jerusalem soyez
dans mes réserves c'était d'avoir la
force colborne bon
[Applaudissements]
nexity
enfin la bécasse 3 que la baule
l'adorent l'autre jour on vous a montré
nadine morano qui confondait le shooteur
le chanteur renaud avec le constructeur
automobile là c'était sur france info et
ils sont passés complètement à côté
les pires que nadine romain nadine
morano regarder si c'était pire rien
renault va embaucher mille personnes en
cdi d'ici la fin de l'année le
constructeur automobile a besoin de main
d'oeuvre pour mener à bien ses nouveaux
projets un reportage à suivre dans l'
usine de sandouville
ouais voilà donc chez meetic est et sur
france info les syriens des génies un
branchement des génies en 18e position
on va aller en 93 c'était patrick poivre
d'arvor patrick poivre d'arvor excuse
moi jean michel c'est pour moi c'est la
pda on va lire pp les achètent plus
simple il un duplex avec l'actrice
américaine holly hunter vous rappelez
dolly hunter très belles graines et
pendant le duplex ya un journaliste il
s'est pris une tarte de fou venu de
nulle part le pauvre regardez la tête du
journaliste vous voyez qui jeudi ont pas
il est connu en plus le mec vous avez
essayé de trouver son nous regarde ça a
été difficile pour vous regarder très
justement le roller d'une
alors écoutez je pense qu'il ya un petit
problème la décidément c'est pas trop je
crois qu'on pourrait avoir le regard
surtout de holly hunter folie vous avez
pu entendre notre eau libre
alain beignet 7e débarbouiller est-ce
que vous pouvez nous dire s'il a été
difficile pour vous deux
s'adapter à cette situation à savoir
essayer de parler un langage particulier
le fond c'était à l'abbé verini le
pauvre était alors au début elle a peur
elle est choquée et puis après elle
rigole
elle m'a fait de la peine à l'image de
la peine le taux est franchement j'ai
presque envie de le revoir mais
peut-être tout à l'heure ça on va se
battre on va s'intéresser en 17e
position on va quitter la france pour le
libre pendant un reportage basique il ya
un mec en arrière-plan qui veut prendre
une photo du journal sauf qu'il a pas vu
où il allait et regardez ce qui se passe
sur la gauche regardez sur la marteline
maubeuge alors candidat sur catane
adossé à la teinte fume un seul et tu
vois et ses boys et basique sa cote
achats quant à ça tu rentres chez toi tu
disais dans la boîte j'ai un truc de fou
c'est exceptionnel les séries avant de
faire thalassa vous rappelez de fanny
agostini on adore faire oui mais elle
elle travaille avec moi sur rtl elle est
très sympathique et elle était madame
météo sur bfm tv et un jour et hu est
arrivé une angoisse de fou on a vu cette
image vous rappeler ou pas regarde mais
aussi qui est monté de façon assez
considérable du côté de saint malo
priorité au direct où vous vous trouvez
fanny agostini fanni qui a les pieds
dans l'eau
attention pas nier en bloc derrière non
alors attendez c'est notre cameraman pu
avoir un petit souci fanny j'ai toujours
là il m'attendait à la double attente
c'est vivifiant famille et je
m'attendais à la douche ce matin
la pauvre mais en plus fanny elle le
prend bien et vous avez un rêve
professionnel fanny agostina prêt
énergie leur tour elles voient sans
rigoler jean michel c'est dangereux ça
sans déconner tu m'as bien sûr il ya les
vagues débordements comme ça il ya des
gens qui sont chaque année qui sont
portés à biarritz ou ailleurs là où il
ya des grandes marées qui peuvent être
emportés au large de petites chutes
milliards et moqué de retour pour la
15ème position brabo la loro dans la
hongrie sa lancée on est sûre laurent
delahousse merci tu n'auras contrainte a
dit demain le maître laurent delahousse
hall tiff le mec il est toujours sergio
et même quand il part en fous rires eh
ben le mec il se contient quand même tu
vois il est un peu classe là c'était
après un magnéto qui montrait des gens
qui glissent et regardez il veut rigoler
mais pas trop ce en 15e position garde
mais pour ceux qui n'en n'ont pas c'est
une autre histoire
et ce matin aller chercher son pain est
une opération périlleuse pour tout le
monde
ce monsieur a trouvé la solution des
chaussettes par dessus les chaussures
vous l'aurez compris avec les 45
départements concernés par ces
intempéries c'est une grande partie du
pays qui va devoir s'habituer à ces
conditions météo
petit tour de france avec caroline
thébaux désormais se bousculent à
trouver la parade des chaussettes au
dessus des choses à moi la vie saissac
affairé au long de la route sur les
connaît c'est sûr et certain
c'est ça mon rebosser sur la barre des
50 sépare c'est obligé honda classe et
sa numéro casser votre top 20 à vous
nous rejoignez on est en direct les
chiffres on passe au numéro 4 janvier
une journaliste en belgique qui nous a
sorti une pépite elle a réussi à casser
à quasi gros sexe pendant un sujet sur
les enseignants sais pas où ça va me
faire là on parle tranquillement des
enseignants et là vous allez voir elle
va caser gros sexe à mon avis c'est de
la famille elle est de la famille de
sophie koch te regarde ce zoo d'achever
sa cousine allant battre les embrasse
les belges regarder
pénurie aussi dont on parle souvent
celle des instituteurs primaires c'est
une réalité dans de nombreuses écoles il
ya davantage de postes à pourvoir que
d'habitude et les congés de maladie ou
les gros sexe n'explique pas tout
reportage de marc bellon à waremme
nadal je suis j'ai peut-être à paris
quand je cois mathieu daris maintenant
ça se voit ça se voit gross est gros 5
se voit qu'elle a vraiment je suis le
vrai mais là vraiment c'est clair
qu'elle pensait qu'on a le temps c'est
vrai aussi
je pense qu'elle y pense et je pense
qu'elle y pense et je pense aussi les
cherry on passe à la 13e position
vous le savez je suis fan de tout ce qui
est flatulences vous savez je suis fan
de benjamin castaldi
ce n'est pas lui c'est une journaliste
suédoise en plein jt qui a un petit
souci
celle là je ne sais pas pourquoi je sens
qu'on va faire passer regarder mais
c'est le second mandat et la focale se
lave les cheveux surtout au plus bas
parce que la pub ne rien dire au début
et après elle ces cas là à la tête
regardez escrocs pour regarder et bravo
pour la couture à mi mandat et la wii
les batteurs 57 et on passe à la
deuxième position
est ce que vous vous souvenez de ce mec
interviewés qui avait détruit la
mauvaise maison sur un chantier vous le
dis je suis un mec le pauvre il et ils
ont envoyé pour détruire une maison et
j'ai la haye devant les caméras et il se
rend compte en fait qu'il a détruit la
mauvaise mais l'ol au pot c'est je crois
que ce qu'il ya de pire qui pouvait lui
arriver
il me fait une peine alors on en rigole
c'est cruel
pour les personnes qui ont perdu leur
maison mais c'est vrai que ces douzièmes
et c'est un des trucs les plus drôles
qui sont passés dans les salles regarde
[Musique]
derrière nous et j'ai eu un ordre
commence à enlever deux maisons qui on
avait le permis et tout ça et puis en
fin de journée ben je me suis rendu
compte par mon patron que j'avais des
mollets la mauvaise foi chara qui l'a
mauvaise
c'est vrai que c'est une petite maison
blanche et le l'autre c'était une petite
aussi eu il ya eu malentendu le regard
des 6 et aura sera mais il peut donner
des explications
ça c'est de vous aimez vous imaginez le
mec à qui on a enlevé la saison mais
sans excès et 10 à regarder
[Musique]
nous et j'ai eu 1 or 2 commence à
enlever deux maisons qui ont elles
permis à tout ça et puis en fin de
journée je me suis rendu compte par mon
patron que j'avais démoli la mauvaise
concert d'ac la mauvaise c'est vrai que
c'est une petite maison blanche et le
lot de certaines petites a aussi eu il
ya eu malentendu contre blanche n'a pas
dit s'il vous plaît il a déjà eu lieu à
un malentendu ou rmi were il te dis ça
comme s'il avait rappelé un arrêt trop
bizarre en afrique les femmes
excuse moi j'ai ri p mais bon c'est la
maison la maison les parties en plus les
voyages officiels mais surtout d'accord
les deux étaient blanches pas quand tu
vois une maison il ya encore la terre la
télé les canapés carrément 11e position
générale en télé quand tu connecte au
téléphone ou tablette pour diffuser des
images je vous le dis c'est qu'il ya un
problème il ya toujours un risque qu'un
truc un peu bizarre passe à l'antenne et
là pendant jt allemand le mec a fait ce
qu'on appelle dans le métier une jean
michel maire regardez ça c'est
complètement fou ces onzièmes le mec qui
bosse son téléphone ou sa tablette et
regarder qui lui arrive
le mec je pense qu'il leur ne leur fera
plus jamais regardé
[Musique]
plutôt bonnes choses mais on peut pas la
voir ça et vous venir
mais si ça nous mais si ça arrive ça
matthieu delormeau dubois son portable
latimore hommes étaient là depuis le
début les chiffres mais c'est ici
[Musique]
c'est plutôt punch au liban qu'est ce
qu'il dit en allemand sous philippe il
déchire en allemand je suis désolé j'ai
juste un tout petit problème avec mon
portable
ça y est le mec ce qu'il a dans son
portable c'est un pari en tout cas
d'école
mais c'est la crise et on voit qu'il ne
voit pas ce qui est en train de passer à
l'antenne il quoi ton téléphone d'adoua
et voit pas c'est pour ça qu'ils restent
calmes et les uns prennent de téléphone
excusez moi ils voient pas d'aller à
toutes les mères qui fasse saison mais
mm
alors on rentre dans les 10 premières
images des jt je sais que vous régaler
avec notre top 20 tous les soirs et en
direct
y'a rien de plus chiant quand tu
annonces un truc et que c'est autre
chose qui part regarder la tête de notre
humble avis ouais c'est ma vie ça moi
c'est ma vie moi ça fait des années que
c'est ça et ben apolline de mahler la
pause
elle est en retour de duplex elle est
magique c'était sur bfm tv ces 10e
regarde invité ce soir louis aliot le
vice président du front national
et merde il fallait annoncer l'actualité
va te faire [ __ ] je la donne elle est
géniale et les chiens mais petit coup de
gueule dans ce top 20 je vois qu'il ya
plein de gens quitter qui tombent tous
les jours sur la tête de bfm tv
je vous le dis moi c'est même pas le
même groupe à séjourner sur ses news
bfmtv c'est juste des mecs qui sont
jaloux parce qu'ils cartonnent et qui
sont premiers
donc forcément si bfm tv personnes les
regards des personnes leur tombe raide
sur envoyer les gens tomber sur lci non
personne n'à oui mais voilà c'est tout
non mais c'est vrai les mecs c'est aussi
simple que ça c'est que c'est que si
comme nous voilà quand on faisait cent
mille téléspectateurs
tout le monde nous a donné un cours de
l'été sur france 4 tournées tarrier
qu'on a fait chier tout le monde voilà
et comme on n'est pas journaliste en
plus forcément s'en est pris plein la
gueule
bfm tv tout le monde leur tombe dessus
tout simplement parce que ma famille
soit en danger des fonds sous bush et
qu'ils ont amené un nouveau truc
alors voila moi j'adore c'est nous que
c'est le groupe cmh elle préférait
d'infos je le dis c'est nous qui monte
en plus mais c'est vrai qu'aux critiques
très peu lci ou france 24
ça c'est sûr que bon ouais merci
ôta on passe en numéro 9 dans les plus
beaux lapsus
on avait celui de la bombe delà de la
bombe
ben voilà on voyons pas dans le plus
beau on avait celui de la tombe du
soldat inconnu
normalement c'est une gerbe que tu
déposes sauf que là ils se sont gourés
évidemment sa part en fous rires et si
encore sur bfm c'est numéro 9
regardez ce lapsus et son fou rire
derrière voyez françois fillon étaient
sur place ce matin aidés à 9h la
socialiste anne hidalgo lui a succédé
ainsi que le fn florian philippon il
était donc tout cela pour déposer une
berge d'une verge d'avon une gerbe
pour le gérant et tous les avis certains
à l'instinct de l'ump dénonce une
récupération
c'est génial et tram il est maintenant
âgée sur cinq ans au huitième position
imagine tu es tranquille en train de
faire ton jt et bien tu reçois un invité
tu te rends compte que tu connais pas le
mec qui est à côté de toi celui là je
voulais passer et je vous leur passe
c'est catherine matausch ça je vous le
dis c'est une des vidéos préférées une
jambe
ces huitièmes elle avec un mec et
regardez bien la tête du mec région va
falloir mettre en garde et t du 12/13
antoine gaudino ex-inspecteur pardon de
la brigade financière du srpj de
marseille
merci d'être d'être avec nous je ne
supporte le candidat pardon excusez moi
vous avez participé indirectement à
cette enquête puisque détente et une
erreur de personnes
que se passe-t-il nous avons un problème
nous avons un problème peut-on
m'expliquer en régie ce qu'est ce
problème vous nous parler nous avons
après nous revenons nous revenons dans
un instant à vous excuser moi de déficit
budgétaire de 97 sera après le vote du
collectif inférieur à celui que la loi
de finances initiale avait près antoine
gaudino le vrai m'a rejoint je rappelle
que vous êtes un ex inspecteur de la
brigade financière du srpj de marseille
parce que le mec le premier et se
retourne et veut pas lui parler et lui
d'autant que dieu je ne suis pas du tout
un godet noé se retourne comme ça et tu
continues à jour est bon et les rôles ou
à regarder bien j'aimerais qu'on voit le
début s'il vous plaît parce que quand à
lui dit ça le mec fait juste à qui je
suis pas du tout fan de pino il retourne
la tête il faut pas la regarder
c'est génial regarder tes du 12/13
antoine gaudino ex-inspecteur pardon de
la brigade financière du srpj de
marseille
merci d'être d'être avec nous je ne
supporte coded là pardon excusez moi
vous avez participé indirectement à
cette enquête puisque doté d'une erreur
de personnes
que se passe-t-il nous avons un problème
nous avons un problème c'est bon et
regarde partout le mec le projet regarde
partout ils cherchent de l'aide gym et
attendait mais je ne suis pas du tout
écoutez ça veut dire deux secondes
avance ya un mec qui était en dehors du
bateau qui va dire en 30 c'est pour toi
mais je ne suis pas du tout la personne
moi j'envisage win your love maquillage
chez l'assistante propre c'est de
chercher ville scission circulent aussi
sûrs et certains allez on passe en
septième position on voit souvent des
techniciens des maquilleuses ou autres
arrivées pendant le jt en général ça
passe inaperçu sauf quand c'est daniel
bilalian d'année bien ok plutôt sympa à
d'habitude lui il a pas qui fait de ouf
on vous a fait une petite compil
regarder ça aussi c'est fou rire c'est
numéro 7 de nos jt avec risque pour la
santé des personnes particulièrement
sensibles
même en cas d'une exposition de cours
voilà un petit problème avec notre un
petit problème avec notre reportage sur
donc la position au [ __ ]
l'ordi dont il faut être droit comme la
justice bah ouais mais alors je
comprends pourquoi vous êtes vous êtes
pourriez dire et rob lowe comme ça je ne
vont pas se tenir
il dirigeait un balai dans le cul voilà
tout ça s'est passé c'est génial ça
s'est passé
la part des crédits habitat l'antenne
alors attention la sixième position de
notre top 20 jt aux pays bas il ya une
journaliste qui a été envoyée sur un
bateau pour interviewer le maire de la
ville
alors c'est un petit kiff sur le papier
elle était contente elle s'est dit joël
et aux pays bas je vais sur un bateau
sauf qu'elle se rétame dans l'eau comme
jamais regardez il ya le maire qui à
côté
ils l'aident pas du tout ils sont fous
complètement vers l'iss un volume et le
quattro dessus passer vos domaines
fonelle entre aurélie et ses occupants
permet sa bâtisse est la vision de la
seo camp page et de vos cheveux au vent
par année oui
l'usld est une bouée je n'aurais jamais
parce que bell et je vous dirais bien
longue et drôle
je suis très fébrile de fer jéquier
déchire décidera non mais j'adorerais y
est juste une bonne voie après c'est
génial c'est la pause c'est parti pour
être au téléphone elle va bien il ya une
règle en télévision c'est que quand tu
lances à magnéto ou une vidéo
faut toujours l'avoir regardé avant sauf
qu'en belgique
visiblement c'était pas trop le cas ces
cinquièmes et ça c'est un immense
sourire ça méritait même la première
place regarde on pour la route de dour
et du festival de rock des concerts qui
attire des festivaliers venus comme l'on
dit d'un peu partout c'est à dire pas
seulement de belgique le reportage sur
place à tour de thomas rooryck via la
drogue et la drogue c'est bien ils ont
dit aussi bas niveau substance qu'on
pouvait prendre ici ça pourrait être
intéressant plus et on n'avait pas vu
sur portage je rappelle quand même que
la drogue c'est dangereux pour la santé
le mec il alors je l'avais pas vu c'est
génial fraioli lance un reportage ils
savent être génial super la dia de la
drogue mais comment ils ont été filmés
ça les mecs c'est incroyable parce que
l'erreur s'est pas tu sais pas tant
qu'ils passent aux reportages là c'est
qu'il ya un mec qui monte ce magnéto et
bien sûr diffusée ce truc là dans le
top4 maintenant je vous le dis du top 20
de nos jt il ya un fou rire que je kiffe
c'était sur le plateau de france 3 un
journaliste reçoit un mec sauf qu'il
n'arrive pas à régler son siège alors le
gars il en galère tout le long et ça
c'est un fou rire exceptionnel c'est
dubéros 4 ça aussi obligé vous allez
rigoler rien de ville de nantes via les
quais on les doit aux américains qu'il a
fait est que l'on voit encore
actuellement ses quais
entre là c'est la poutrelle de béton
entre la c sont en fait des quais pour
l'essentiel à mes yeux et puis dernière
chose le département a eu lieu donc ça
m'a un petit voyage
julian sur l'unique 72 merci le muc 72
le club de football qui vivent au
contraire je vous laisse découvrir le
reportage est fourni et d'allumer de la
sensée et cela parce que le mec qui
parle très sérieux c'est vrai que ça va
être un déconneur c'est pas la même
rigolo là le mec pas très sérieux
regardez là on voit ses bureaux 4 leur
boîte de l'île de nantes via les quais
on les doit aux américains qui a
fabriqué que l'on voit encore
actuellement ses quais entre là c'est la
poutrelle de béton entrelacés sont en
fait des quais pour l'essentiel
américain et puis dernière chose le
département a eu lieu donc ça c'est pas
un petit qui reviennent sur 72 merci le
muc72 les clubs de football tingrela
parce que le mec qui veut faire genre il
s'est rien passé tout va bien pendant
tout est sous contrôle ne l'inquiétait
pas tout est sous contrôle tout et berné
vous pas évoqué ce genre tout se passe
bien le mec génial
il est génial allez on va passer au
numéro trois au 33 de notre jt les 20
plus grosses l'image du jt les 20 plus
drôle mon numéro 3 on vous d'été obligé
de mettre benoît poelvoorde c'était pour
la sortie du film le vélo il s'était
incrusté dans un duplex de jt belge
c'est un moment exceptionnel ça c'est
numéro 3 on s'en lasse pas regarder
quelles sont les grandes lignes de ce
festival ne vous retournez pas je crois
que quelqu'un vous suis l'un ouais je
suis bien encadré je suis bien encadré
et bien fabienne on peut dire tout
d'abord que le festival international du
film francophone c'est tout d'abord une
ville qui se transforme namur vivre au
rythme du festival on a un oui jour on
pourra voir bois voir ici 150 films dans
trois salles différentes on a même ici
aménagé au coeur de la ville une salle
pour la projection de ce soir alors le
festival depuis son origine se bat pour
et bien promouvoir les cinéastes
francophones de par le monde
bonjour bonsoir benoît et donc à l'issue
de cette semaine le jury va bien se
récompenser des films messi qui prévaut
à namur c'est bien sûr la convivialité
vous l'aurez remarqué
on vient ici pour rencontrer des
comédiens et ils sont facilement
accessibles
alors paul henry on faisait jusqu'ici un
cadre semblant de rien mais il ya
d'android qui s'est jetée oui pour le
psg ce soir le film d'ouverture c'est
donc
l'algue ouvert benoît bonsoir
effectivement
ils ont tous appuyé mais qu'est ce
qu'ils font bordel c'est le numéro trois
de nos jeunes un boulevard qui est
exceptionnel web aujourd'hui ce qui est
acquis le jour d ici là il avait vaudois
plus vendu leurs bureaux faire un truc
incroyable jouer avec lui on fait alors
alors je vais vous dire moi je trouve
qu'il a eu la bonne attitude l'image est
beaucoup plus drôle comme ça quand ils
restent sérieux je trouve ça s'entend
plus rude pour la postérité oui cent
fois plus drôle allez sur en tête de
série numéro 2 à l'époque on voyait la
régie derrière les journalistes avec les
écrans ça veut dire qu'ils avaient agité
qui passait en fait j'avais tous les
écrans derrière
sauf que ce soir là sur une des télés ce
n'était pas un reportage sur les
mocassins à glands qu'ils regardent et
se passer mais on enlève le mot dresse
un regarde voilà et le président russe a
également mis en garde les militaires
contre toute tentative de coup d'état
on ne prendra plus jamais le pouvoir à
la force des baïonnettes
le président russe doit aussi faire face
un autre mécontentement c'est celui des
ménagères
lorsque les produits sont de plus en
plus rares et que les prix grimpent
c'est pourquoi boris eltsine s'est rendu
dans plusieurs villes il a mis en cause
la désorganisation du circuit de
distribution et surtout le rôle de la
mafia
c'est génial ça le mec va tellement bien
avec le truc aussi le journaliste et les
tellement sérieux il sait pas à la à la
fin ils ont dû lui dire il ya eu un il y
avait un petit problème il a dû gueuler
je suis sur les cherry et on va
découvrir le numéro un je vous le dis le
numéro un pour moi c'est un de mes plus
gros fous rires de toute l'histoire de
la télé je pense que ce mec là je ne le
connais pas mais je suis fan absolu il
me fait pleurer de rire c'est pour moi
le fou rire le plus mythique à la télé
le mec vient de découvrir le nom
improbable d'une rivière en russie je
crois que c'est en russie et la russie
s'appelle prout
franchement ce celui-ci je l' ai vu
mille fois là j'ai qu'une envie c'est de
le revoir
il est numéro 1 c'est génial regarder
cette tête et on l'a plus jamais revu le
mec après regarde
en moldavie ancienne république
soviétique des inondations d'une extrême
importance ont fait au moins 50 morts
dans le centre du pays et les dégâts
sont colossaux selon l'expression du
premier ministre
pendant deux jours des pluies
torrentielles se sont abattues près de
la capitale chisinau
le bilan pourrait s'aggraver et le
nombre des victimes augmenter le niveau
de la rivière la prout s'est élevé de 5
mètres en quelques heures
c'est vrai en plus
[Rires]
al'approche de l'open américain ont pour
fonction de l'année dernière finaliste
cédric pioline retrouve qu'à former ils
se disent il s'est qualifié pour la
finale à paris new york
pardonnez moi et qui affrontera le russe
kafelnikov sur le quartier j'arrive bien
décoller parce qu'en plus c'est un sujet
hyper sérieux le gars sérieux mais il
pleure de rire les chéris raymond à
chaque fois je te demandais ce que tu
vas en avoir une pour le kiff mon chéri
c'est toujours moi c'est compliqué j'ai
bien aimé celui qui est tombé que les
chaussettes au début mais c'est vrai
c'est vrai que c'est ça qui demande aux
autres parce que moi c'est celui
remettez mois les chaussettes avec
laurent delahousse allez c'est parti
ses désirs et bon qui sait cette femme
qui se rappelle mais pour ceux qui n'en
n'ont pas c'est une autre histoire
et ce matin aller chercher son pain est
une opération périlleuse pour tout le
monde
ce monsieur a trouvé la solution des
chaussettes par dessus les chaussures
vous l'aurez compris avec les 45
départements concernés par ces
intempéries c'est une grande partie du
pays qui va devoir s'habituer à ces
conditions météo
petit tour de france avec caroline
thébaux désolé en fait j'ai compris
pourquoi il rigolé on laurent delahousse
grâce à toi remo puisqu'on la revue
regarder quand le mec il josette j'avais
pas vu il ya l'autre derrière il se fera
grâce aux 3 1 mais c'est génial du toit
l'autre cas il y fera qu'à regarder ils
ont la chance on la sent sont ces bons
d'achat chez qui elle est et vu le mec
c'était génial